looking for sympathy has this guy ever
lifted a baby out of a skip and wrapped
it up
as this guy ever had to defend himself
as this guy ever put limbs and stuff
in bags was i looking for sympathy doing
this last year
no it's called awareness mate it's
called awareness
awareness that people are suffering
[Music]
hi i'm craig um former sniper in the
british army
i did a video last year in december and
i'm here now to answer some of your
comments
i didn't know it was going to do so well
it's overwhelming
i didn't realize that i'd have so much
of an impact
just by saying that i nearly committed
suicide
you know and and breaking down and
crying
i never knew i have such an impact on
people i come from
the badass story oh sorry i came from
the badass stories left in tears
i just like to say sorry for about when
i'm reading i'll get a bit stumbled
um obviously i've got shot on the helmet
in my head on the right side and also
blown up
so i've got a brain injury and so i find
reading quite a struggle
i made a lot of people
tearful on when i did my first interview
on
lad bible and it wasn't my intentions to
make people
upset or cry but i did
and i think i've inspired people because
they look at me
i'm six foot four i weigh 19 stone
i train every day i'm a bloke's bloke
but also i've got emotion and i do cry
and it's good
to release that emotion and do and you
know and
for people that do cry especially blokes
is there's nothing
wrong with it at all you know you should
uh
be proud of yourselves did you get much
response from people who you served with
a lot of people reached out due to that
video they didn't realize how much i was
hurting
with my ptsd and my mental health i hid
it quite well
in in the the regiment but near the end
i didn't hide it too well
because i got discharged he gives a real
insight in how ptsd can affect military
personnel i wish him all the best
thank you it does infect you
and some days it sounds cliche but i
wish
i might have lost a limb or something so
i'm not festering inside as much you
know
because when people look at you and you
say yeah i've been blown up
they look you up and down to make sure
if you've got a missing arm have you got
a missing leg
but i'm not damaged that way i'm damaged
up here and that's what some people need
to be aware of as well
it's not all about physicality it's
about mental as well
he's a soft hearted lad really that's
why he's eating
up with that's why he's eating up with
guilt
i won't say i'm a soft lad but
i'm a normal person you know i think if
you go around and enjoy what you do
killing and you're enjoying it you've
got something wrong
you're not all there i think when i got
blown up i think that wall that
shattered when i got blown up like i've
said
everything just came and i couldn't
control it you know all the guilt came
all the remorse came and you you're
overwhelmed by it
but you try and um you try and hold it
back you try and build another wall
again trying to
hold all that guilt and remorse back but
sometimes it doesn't work
um but i've got no i've got no um
yeah that's a hard one that one was a
hard one
i couldn't help but tear up with him
when he was talking about
taking his own life and looking at his
dog
i put the bullet in cocked it put it in
my mouth
and betsy was sat on the back of the
sofa
she's um little yorkshire terrier
and her head tilted until the other way
and i just stared at her
yeah i sold it sold it got rid of it
saved my life she's um
she's 16 this year so she's getting on a
bit
and um just wanted to live forever you
know
are you doing good hmm
this is betsy
and is 16-9 16
yeah and she's coffee she got a bit
blind a bit deaf
but um
big impact in my life
you know just well i feel down or
i get upset i just hold her she seems to
know
you know she's she's
she's in me she's we've got like a soul
connection
she's amazing and um
yeah my wife always says to me you know
she is getting old
and i understand she's getting old but i
always in the back of my head i'm going
to live forever
she'll live forever we'll live forever
when we go
that's it come on
respect warrior god bless you
for sharing and kudos to your wife
and the man's best friend suicide is
huge
problem and this will help others be rad
be kind it is
um i see suicide there you know um
it's strange everyone thinks i'm strong
everyone thinks i'm a strong man
you know everyone thinks
he's done this thing on lad's bible god
he's a strong man
you know he can talk about it but i i
think
i think about suicide every day when i
wake up
when i go to bed and it's hard you know
and
my big thing is is
i've got a big heart and
if i committed suicide somebody's got to
find me
and
to find me i've infected somebody with
my problem and they don't even know me
so i try and battle that as well and
that's why i
try and subside all them suicidal
thoughts if i can
it's interesting how veterans have a
hard time
using the word kill or killed
it is it is especially veterans with
ptsd
or severe ptsd because
you don't be reminded all the time of
everything that you've done
you know being a sniper is quite
personal you're looking for that scope
you're getting to know that person
you're getting to know everything about
that person
before you take that target out so it's
quite personal you know
and um yeah i
i don't really like saying killed or
killed but a lot of people on my
instagram as well
or people that have talked to me through
media
always who are interested in how many
people you've killed
killed killed killed killed it's not
about killing it's about the pain
afterwards and that's what i try to get
across
looking for sympathy
not really not really as this guy
ever lifted a baby out of a skip
and wrapped it up as this guy ever had
to defend himself
as this guy ever put limbs and stuff in
bags
i was doing the job and i did my job to
100
of my ability was i looking for sympathy
doing this last year
no it's called awareness mate it's
called awareness
awareness that people are suffering and
if you've never suffered
you've got no right to put sympathy
a killer is still a killer no matter
what helmet he puts on
why sorry war isn't a video game
why choose to get in
to if you can't handle it this guy's a
[ __ ]
i can handle it and i've handled a lot
of things
um god i wish i knew when i was still in
i would take you out not take you out
but i'll take you out into the field and
show you what puss is all about show
what real soldiers all about
and that's what i'd love to do but it's
just comments on a computer isn't it
does it make you angry yeah it does yeah
because i'm no
[ __ ] no way because i cry
because i've seen it no it means i'm
human
means i've got emotion and it means i'm
real
yeah i'm no [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was incredible they should have
made a film about
his life prize fighting foreign legion
sniper tours that i've done yeah it'd be
pretty good
i think my wife would like um tom hardy
to play me though
yeah that's what that's so uh that's the
end line
so she can meet don hardy that's correct
yeah
prize fighting great what's this i never
heard about this yeah i
used to do when i was in night switch um
i used to do a bit of price fighting
used to get 350 pound a fight
and i used to do three fights a night
and that's the reason one of the reasons
why i left nightswitch
in london and went to windsor to take me
out the london scene because
i was going down there the wrong path
and i didn't want that but
easy money were you good i held my own
i held my own i hope he gets help the
mental
health is so much more important than
anything else
some days i think i wake up and i feel
fine and i think
i'm alright today and then it gets
heavier
and heavier and then heavier so wearing
a backpack and people putting bricks in
it
you know and you realize that you do
have mental health problems
but um i do get help
this is one of the most powerful things
that i've ever watched
the things he did were hard talking
about them
are harder that's a real man what he's
doing is so important
speaking up we need more people like
this man
that's what it's all about is talking
and that's how that's how easy mental
health is to combat
is talking talking talking talking
you're not alone
there's always somebody out there
willing to listen to you
a friend a family member even a total
stranger
sometimes but yeah it's important to
talk
not to bottle up more you bottle it more
infested inside of you
more infects you you need to get out and
be positive about it
missed my first shot second shot i got
him and then i had to go up
to the body to to see if i'd um
if he he was you know dead and i
remember walking up to the body
um the motorbike the the throttle was
stuck in the sand
and the bike was revving and an ak strap
to it
and uh the guy was on the floor and
he he passed away um he
i'd shot him here
yeah weird weird feeling weird feeling
you feel like you're in trouble
you feel i've just killed someone